have you ever fallen in love with a
client no I mean like in tiny ways like
micro loves
like have you ever fallen in love love I
mean I don't know what it means but
probably the thing that other people say
when they say fall in love is probably
something I've experienced
what do you think they mean
um
what is love yeah I know no it's a
fantastic question I think so love is
one of those words that refers to like a
billion different concepts and I think
we maybe should just taboo the term to
have a better understanding what we're
referring to because there's things like
I feel like intense attachment there's
something feeling like like soulfully
aligned there's like sexual attraction
there's like are you excitement talking
to me and saying we should taboo the
term beloved in this conversation how
dare you no uh yeah
okay
romantic love to make it flourish into
lots of other new definitions okay thank
you very much it sounds like you're
censoring the most important word this
is like 1984 all over again
okay also on the book a reading list oh
okay listen uh no romantic love like a
deep intimacy for somebody else like
like a deep connection with a human
being that is also
I mean yeah with polyamory It's Tricky
and your relationship with sex is also
sex is also tricky so like what's the
difference between a deep friendship
and that and a friendship that also has
a sexual component I remember being very
confused about that when I did a lot of
LSD I was like what uh the the lying
between romantic relationships and
everything else kind of got blurred I
was like oh I'm just like in intimacy
and some intimacies mean that you spend
your life together more and have sex but
like
and the the same basic thing is there
like you're seeing someone for like who
they are
do you think you can be if you're
heterosexual do you think you could be
really deeply close with friends with a
guy and not have sexual relationships
with him I assume it's possible like if
anything is ever possible then probably
yeah
like everything is possible time travel
is possible quantum mechanics makes
every traveling faster than the speed of
light is possible according general
relativity everything's possible so
you're saying there's a chance Dumb and
Dumber has taught taught me that
everything it's probably impossible not
super likely assuming that they are like
attracted to each other yeah
and for somebody that has surveys and
statistical analysis
we're interested in like what's the
likely thing here versus like what's
possible if you say possible it's like
where anything's open did you just avoid
answering the love thing okay I have a
lot to say about love it's just you like
to be precise yeah okay let's be uh
precisely and precise and continue I'm
sorry that's my phone
uh
it feels like a passive aggressive
suggestion that we shouldn't talk about
love anymore but we shall continue we
should absolutely talk about love it's
just the term is very confusing because
like some people say the word love and
the thing that they're thinking of is
like oh the butterflies like the sparkle
thing that I get in my stomach when I
think about my loved one but I study
relationships over time I just really
like I did a survey about it and that
sparkle goes away within like two to
four years but people still report
loving their partner after that so I'm
like okay like when you say the word
love like what the [__] are we talking
about
yeah that's going to get on the same
page okay so what are the different so
the butterflies
boy I'd like to push back down two to
four years on the butterflies but okay I
mean statistically not everybody
I butterflies don't give a [__] about
statistics you ever heard of the like
the butter the flap of a butterfly wing
causing like nuclear war
how do you describe that with your
statistics
uh okay so butterflies that's the basic
confession infatuation in the chemistry
of the initial interactions sure but a
deep meaningful connection like
that feels
like sexuality is a component of that
like the kind of intimacy that's only
possible when you're also sexual with
another human being on top of that you
have the butterfly and on top of that
you have the friendship and on top of
that you have like what is that that's a
sandwich full of the love sandwich the
love sandwich okay I'm down to call it a
love sandwich okay Sam would you call
sandwich l l us okay what role does that
play in The Human Condition like he asks
me about The Human Condition it's an
interesting phrase yeah I'm not like I'm
like this like not a phrase that's
common in my own thinking
sure Human Condition is a good
summary you know what do you think what
do you feel when you when I when I say
very different kinds of questions in you
sure yeah which is interesting I've been
trying to like figure out like what kind
of brain that you have is like creating
like this category of question which is
why it's like saying like there's
something about a poetic narrative in
there yeah because it's very like like
aesthetic I think you've asked much more
aesthetic questions than I do I don't
even know what the word aesthetic means
like artistic artistic yeah well I mean
I know what aesthetic means but I also
don't know what it means it's kind of
like the word love
aesthetic perspective yeah well me but
part of it in conversation you don't
want to ask a question that has an
answer
fully always
do you have an example of a question
that has what's the meaning of oh
does has an answer like one that you was
like oh that's like a bad question
because it has an answer how many sexual
partners you had in the last year oh my
God
okay I feel like we just like got to
some sort of Crux of it like the kinds
of questions that we like to answer sure
because I would love that question okay
right to ask enough people all right but
that's does that really tell the story
okay of of what you've felt over the
past year
that's that's true but then I could just
tell you okay so why by when you're
saying the kinds of questions that you
like the ones that don't have an answer
but not an answer you mean like not an
answer where
you can know that you're done telling it
that you can escape having to think by
actually answering it I see
yeah
the struggle
is the place where we discover something
not not the uh not the destination yeah
okay it's working it's working okay so
what is the role of the love sandwich in
The Human Condition okay that's fine I
take I take that question but it's a
stupid question you don't have to it's
I'm ready to do you like do you like
love do you personally like love yeah I
mean I I think like there's a part of me
that feels like I have unconditional
love for all things like when you're
talking about the class being beautiful
I've felt that like that feels like it
felt like it rang something that like I
have a similar resonance in me for that
if I were to Circle
right now I I feel like you're avoiding
the love question
it's a lot of sandwich question
what's your own personal feeling towards
loving another human being versus having
sex with another human being
I I think
I love is like one of the concepts that
dissolved for me a long time ago so I
have difficulty directly answering it
sure but I have the experience when you
describe the love sandwich I feel like I
have had that experience I have it
currently for some people also like I'm
dating people and I have that so people
who you date you you would describe
sharing a love sandwich with them yeah
okay so how does uh
uh I mean that's great to hear so you're
not Are You Afraid Of Love no not at all